pftot pft pm pft whatever wherever
however some extra things that chris
sims and i didn't get to on the thursday
edition of the show we had fun for the
past couple of hours at uh talking a lot
about the nfc north their draft needs
and the best players from that division
and a lot about the tom brady interview
with howard stern for two hours on
uh on wednesday and you know
after
hearing that
and looking at everything he had to say
like what more does tom brady have to
like
who would even want to interview him at
this point right like what more can you
get out of tom brady that howard stern
hasn't gotten out of him
no you're right i mean well we've never
really heard brady open up like that at
all other than like maybe the that
series that came out you know tom first
time you know that's why it's just so
intriguing of a listen all together you
know yes he's been in new england where
they train you to be a robot i'm sure
he's been a little reluctant to do
interviews like that because he just
knows that new england culture doesn't
love that uh but you're right there
ain't much more to cover he kind of gave
it he gave it gave it all to us
well you know what i'll maybe make a
request for him uh
to see if we can get him on the show
what that he did it three years ago
after super bowl 51 we had him for like
20 minutes
on like a tuesday morning not long after
the super bowl so well hey if he's ready
to talk let's give him the platform i
mean what else is going on right now you
know that's how you get a draft after
the draft things are really going to
slow down and maybe that's when we start
lining up some of these guys who
otherwise aren't doing anything although
i know they're going to be trying to
work out at home but they're going to
have a lot more free time than they
would in a normal year so maybe they
want to come promote something or talk
about something or you know just hang
out for a few minutes and have some fun
maybe talk about them some things uh
that they otherwise wouldn't be talking
about all right here's what we're gonna
talk about a report from the dog that is
owned by my internet son pft commenter
chris i don't know how much you follow
this but leroy insider the dog owned by
pft commenter from time to time breaks
news on twitter now
i will say this
leroy is not batting a thousand so i i'm
always a little bit nervous i'm a little
bit nervous when i when i see something
leroy reports like the bears are having
dinner with eli manning uh that was one
that was uh that was posted by leroy a
few weeks back but but this one caught
my attention because it's not
implausible
leroy insider tweeted last night that
there are rumors that rob gronkowski is
gonna come out of retirement and join
tom brady with the tampa bay buccaneers
now for starters that can't happen
without the patriots approval because
he's on the patriots reserve retired
list they'd have to trade him or they'd
have to cut him before he could become a
buccaneer but but assuming they could
work out the transactional side of it
could you see rob gronkowski choosing to
come back and play football with tom
brady in tampa
i could i could see him thinking about
it for sure i you know again
you know are two things that jump out to
me here you know one just watching what
was that wrestlemania two weeks ago or
just seeing little snippets of it or
maybe that was sunday i can't even
remember now the days you're running
together he does look like he's put on a
little bit more weight like he's been
lifting weights a little lately so
that you know i know he's probably doing
it for the the wrestlemania show but
nonetheless might have got him in the
mode a little bit to be like oh man i
missed working out this feels good okay
i feel pretty good and of course
training for that event in itself maybe
you know could have ignited his fire a
little bit and then also hey listen just
like brady kind of being worn out by the
new england way i i wouldn't be shocked
if that's what happened to the gronk a
little too where it just is you know the
grind of new england caught up to him
let alone the physical toll and he loves
brady we know that and you know they
have good tight ends in tampa they can
make a trade happen if they wanted it's
interesting nonetheless i don't think
it's crazy
yeah you could send o.j howard or
cameron breit to the patriots for the
rights to rob gronkowski it's that
simple if gronk wants to do it and let's
also be realistic about it because you
and i were quick to call bs on the idea
that the buccaneers didn't talk to tom
brady prior to
the opportunity for them legally to do
so under nfl rules surely they were
talking to brady and would it shock
anyone
to know whether or not uh bruce arians
the coach of the buccaneers has maybe
had some conversations with gronk right
and that wouldn't surprise me either and
for gronk bruce arians is the perfect
coach
gronk had gotten worn out by bill
belichick here comes bruce arians with a
drink in one hand and he's dropping
f-bombs and he's got the kangal hat on
this guy's cool in the eyes of rob
gronkowski this is the kind of guy that
gronk would come out of retirement for
especially if it puts him back together
with his good buddy tom brady i mean it
makes a ton of sense on the surface and
if they could work out this transaction
if there's a way to make that deal
happen
it would not shock me we spent so much
time last year speculating on whether or
not gronk would unretire and play with
brady with the patriots obviously he
ultimately didn't i think now we're
going to be on this idea of whether or
not there's going to be a path for gronk
back to brady to tampa out of new
england it'd be fascinating if it
happens yeah it would be fascinating and
you know like i mean i think we made a
lot of good points to why it you know
is not totally out of left field i think
there's a lot of things that match up
that you go that's a positive i could
see that happening and you're right you
know aryans i just think aryans would be
a welcome refreshment to guys like gronk
and brady and brady brady will probably
be able to even help sell it like that
to gronk if he is thinking about it uh
but be interesting certainly something
to keep an eye on here because hey we do
know this too the patriots have a need
at the tight end position and of course
you know there's nobody that knows how
to use the tight end as good as new
england so they might see value in just
letting him go and get getting a younger
prospect like a braider oj howard
who do you want if you're bill belichick
cameron braider o j howard yeah that's a
really tough one i mean braid is a
little bit more consistent oj howard is
you know a physical freak in a lot of
ways and has some top end talent but
just has not played
to the level that of course the first
round draft pick which we would expect
you know i think cameron breaks a little
bit more of a sure thing right now and a
little bit better of an all-around
football player uh
yeah i think it would i think i would
probably favor break uh in a close one
yeah breit uh is a guy who emerged and
was having some good seasons before
howard came along he had 680 receiving
yards in 2016 and eight touchdowns then
howard came along in 2017 as a rookie
howard had 432 and breit that year had
591 but howard has been more productive
the past two years and last year it was
459 receiving yards for howard only 311
for breit but brade is a guy they
recently redid a contract with may have
extended him more years into the future
he's been around for a while he's still
only 28 though he turns 29 on july the
3rd oj howard i look at it this way
he played at alabama for nick saban
bill belichick would be able to pick up
the phone and find out exactly what make
makes oj howard tick in one conversation
with nick saban so
before belichick makes his final
decision that conversation is going to
occur
and uh
we'll know
based upon which guy he wants we'll know
how that conversation goes with nick
saban if it goes well it'll be howard if
it doesn't it'll be camera break uh the
harvard guy who will be coming back to
the boston area if that's the deal that
ultimately occurs but it's not
outlandish it's not ridiculous it's one
of those things that makes so much sense
it may make too much sense and it won't
happen for that reason
right no i i'm there with you you're
right and you're right about the o.j
howard points a great point by you i
mean i wouldn't be shocked if
belichick's probably already had that
conversation with nick saban a few years
back and really knows what oj howard is
but yeah something to keep an eye on
here during the off season
there was some chatter last year about
o.j howard maybe being available would
it shock you to know if this were the
truth that before the second round pick
got sent to the falcons for muhammad
sunu that maybe they called the tampa
bay buccaneers jason light former
patriots employee easy pipeline there
hey jason are you willing to part ways
with o.j howard so maybe they've already
sniffed around the possibility chris
yeah no i think that's real too i think
there's a lot of teams that probably
sniffed around oj howard last year
you're right that was a very real rumor
going around the nfl tampa being a
little disappointed with what they got
out of oj howard the first few years of
his career so
yeah i i'm with you mike i think there's
a lot of dots that connect here that
make a lot of sense
that topic by the way sparked by a
question on twitter from at poundtown 10
who wanted to know whether or not it was
realistic as leroy insider reported that
maybe rob gronkowski could be bound for
the buccaneers max hiller too has a
question about the buccaneers and tom
brady simple question chris what are the
realistic expectations for brady in
tampa
well i think winning football games
taking care of the football at a high
greater level than what's been done
there the last few years like hey i
don't sit here and go
oh man tom brady's gonna throw 40
touchdown passes and five interceptions
you know i think within this offense
brady might throw a few more
interceptions than we're accustomed to
him seeing you know accustomed to him to
him throwing but not by a lot i mean it
might go from you know usually he throws
like six seven eight interceptions now
we might throw 10 or 11 and i think
you'll see 25 or 26 touchdown passes but
a more aggressive tom brady is what i
think we can expect and if the
buccaneers pass defense can get a little
bit better and i did they do have young
talent i mean i think realistic
expectations i i wouldn't sit here and
go oh it's crazy if they won the nfc
south you know i'm favoring the saints
but i'm not going to sit here like just
in shock and awe like if it's next
december and the and the bucks are in
the lead no there's a lot of talent
there in that team so i think playoffs
division winner uh and brady having a
really solid year are all
realistic things to expect
yeah i i absolutely agree with you last
year they were close even with a guy
coughing up 30 interceptions
they win a couple games here or there
that they lost last year and all of a
sudden this is a playoff team and
they're going to be a very exciting team
this season if there's a season and
tampa bay hosting the super bowl
wouldn't that be something wouldn't that
be a way oh my god
his first year post patriots getting to
the super bowl played in his new home
stadium all right another question this
one comes from peter brewski 357 and
this relates to the team that tom brady
left the patriots is jared stidham
really ready for prime time chris what
do you think well i you know i can't
give that answer you know but all i can
do is go i really like what i saw from
the preseason i really liked what i saw
from him coming out in the draft out of
auburn he played a lot of big football
games in auburn you know his junior year
you know that auburn was one of the best
teams in college football so from that
standpoint hey yes he's ready and again
you know mike you know you've heard me
say this a lot
people in new england they rave about
jared sidham we've heard the players
rave about them ever since tom brady
switched teams and i know there's a
really quiet confidence within the
coaching staff too and what stidhum
brings so you know at the face level if
bill belichick thinks he's ready for
prime time then yes i'm right now going
to believe he's ready for prime time as
well
yeah i agree with you look they know him
better than anyone and when you have
stefan gilmore devin mccourty matt
slater going on the record to praise him
and and gilmore and mccordy specifically
talking about what stidhum does it
practice to help the defense get better
those are all important signs that now
that's a far cry from doing it in
practice versus doing it in the game but
when you're when you're going in
practice against a great defense like
that that helps accelerate your
preparation to face lesser defenses in
games that count chris
no doubt about it i mean there is no
doubt a great scout time scout team
quarterback who can execute the other
team's offense
and play the position with a little bit
of a style of the team you're gonna face
that quarterback this week there is
great value in that and then of course
you know
his ability to test the defense itself
every day in practice and you know not
let them fall asleep at the wheel and
continue to push and throw big time
throws there yes that makes a great team
great uh it really does it's those
little things and i think statum has a
lot of physical ability that will pop
off the screen to people this year when
we watch them in the preseason and
regular season if we have one
all right last topic for today john
pascal asks what's the bigger threat to
the chiefs the denver broncos or the la
chargers oh
man
you know oof that's a really good one
because i look at the broncos for one of
those teams to say watch out for it i
think you agree with me i mean you know
again that defense is really good
bradley chubb will be back they got
jarrell casey they traded for aj
bouillier
you know there's some things there you
look at and go wow and of course the
drew lock factor
but i think for right now i'm going to
stick with the chargers for right now i
am just because it's i guess there's a
little more of a proven commodity there
in that defense they were in the
playoffs two years ago they've improved
their offensive line there are weapons
at receiver you know tyrod taylor's
certainly not as sexy as drew locke to
me but he has taken the team to the
playoffs so you know i really like the
prospects of what denver could do but i
think right now i'd probably give the
edge to the chargers
yeah look i'm excited by what the
denver's con the denver broncos can do
with drew lockett quarterback it was
great to see it late in the year last
year the defense is going to be better
in vic fangio's second season we've
talked about how great pat shurmur could
do with that offense
the arrival of melvin gordon i i think
the broncos are a bigger threat i i
think that they haven't been all that
far off the past couple of years and you
know like so many of these other teams
you know we see a team turn it around
quickly some of these teams are turning
around and go from non-playoffs to
playoffs they weren't that far out of
the playoffs in the first place
and you make one adjustment here one
adjustment there and you've bent
the the one loss record in your favor
and i could see them overcoming the
charges i could see them being the
number two team in the division this
year maybe a wild card team maybe a real
threat to the chiefs if there's any type
of a super bowl hangover in kansas city
i i'm excited about what the broncos can
do now would i like to see drew lock
have the benefit of a full off-season
program yes but uh i i think he
we saw him get thrust into the fray last
year after he'd missed all that time
with the wrist injury and he was fine
he's got that quiet confidence that
looseness that i think you need to have
in in a potentially great quarterback
he's not freaked out by the moment he
loves it he embraces it he relishes it
you were all over him last year as a
potential first round pick he slid
around too and uh i think he's going to
prove a lot of people wrong starting
this year yeah well you know again he's
the perfect example of another guy where
if he came out the year before he's
going to be a slam dunk top 20 pick but
he stayed in one more year the team fell
apart and then everybody viewed him
differently because they we all blamed
the quarterback for everything pass
protection whether the quarter the
receivers catch the ball i mean it's
just crazy how we do that but he's
played a lot of football in the sec and
mike and you hit on it you hit on all
the right points he does have a very
nice quiet confidence about him and he
does not seem rattled by anything let
alone you and i saw him make a lot of
big time talented throws last year and i
think that should excite denver i mean
listen i picked the chargers but i'm
with you i hear you with a lot of the
things you're saying with denver denver
is one of those teams i you know you got
to say watch out for this year in the
afc
yeah i mean either way the afc west
now the chiefs are still clearly the
team to beat but those other three teams
raiders chargers broncos they're going
to have a hell of a scrum they're on the
right potentially for a wild card both
and remember remember there's an extra
wild card berth available this year so
there's three spots for the teams that
finish in second or third place and you
know in theory and and i'd be stunned if
this happens but we have seen three
playoff teams come from a division
before in theory you could have all four
teams from the same division make it to
the playoffs that's crazy and you're
right i never even thought about that
until you just started you know going
down that road and i went damn you're
right i mean if you saw a team
that
kind of dominated their their other
divisions and their schedule and then
you know kind of were one and one versus
each other within their own division
you're right you might get four teams
that are all around you know eleven and
five ten and six nine and seven and they
all could end up making the playoffs
which is crazy i hadn't really thought
about that yet
it really isn't all that out of the
question if you have everyone right
around three and three in the divisional
play that's ten other games and if
they're playing a weak division in their
own conference because they play all
four teams from one of the other
divisions in their own conference a weak
division from the other conference
that's eight games right you could have
all the teams eight knows six and two
seven and one five and three against
those two divisions you have teams that
are in position to to steal
not just obviously a division
championship but three wild card spots
i'm i'm kind of rooting for that i kind
of wanted to see that happen
it'd be kind of cool it really would you
know i'm looking at like hey look at the
afc south last year you had houston at
ten and six tennessee at nine and seven
the colts at seven and nine you know the
jaguars at six you know i'm trying to
you know just look at teams and go yeah
i mean you're right a few different wins
and losses and all of a sudden we you
know again we could see the very real
possibility of eight and eight teams
making the playoffs now too to where you
go wow this this really could happen
you know it's funny how you you trip
over these topics when you answer fan
questions the question wasn't even on
this but this is something i think i'm
gonna write about at pft because here's
the real question
should the last place team in the
division be prevented from going to the
playoffs for example if it would be all
for should you say for the same reason
team that gets first place hey they get
they get that home game in the playoffs
even if their record is lesser than a
wild card teams should you say if you
come in last in a four team race you
don't get to the postseason it's going
to go to some other team from some other
division this second place team from one
of the other three divisions
i
no i i think you should get in i don't
care you know again especially if it
goes down the scenario we talked about
where you know your inter-division your
inter-division games are split but yet
you've dominated the other divisions
you're playing in the afc and nfc
you know you've proven that you're
worthy of being in there and i don't i
don't think that's crazy man i mean you
look at a few divisions here there's a
few where you're right you just take a
few wins from the top team and just
spread it around the division a little
bit you go man it could be a very real
possibility i mean the nfc west if the
49ers you know dropped just a little bit
and then you know the arizona cardinals
climb the ladder a little bit you could
have a whole bunch of teams there around
ten and six nine and seven eleven and
five i mean it's it's very interesting
and let me take a quick look at this the
49ers this year they are due to play the
teams of the so this would be all four
teams from the nfc west 49ers cardinals
rams seahawks they play all the teams of
the nfc east which was one of the worst
divisions in football last year and they
play all the teams of the afc east which
is going to be in flux this year they
don't have tom brady who knows who's
going to be good out of that division
and you have the best division in
football with the seahawks the rams the
49ers in the cardinals it could happen
the first year of this you could have
all
teams from the nfc west
take the wild card berths out of the the
nfc i i i i'm kind of rooting for it i
kind of want it to happen
me too i come with you i think it would
be really cool yes it would be cool i
want i want football chaos i've had
enough other chaos
i have to amend i have to amend my
position that i want chaos i need to be
clear i want chaos only in the world of
football and look we appreciate having
the opportunity to talk to you all every
day it helps us manage the things that
are going on in the real world and we
try to provide you on an ongoing basis a
break from all of that and hopefully
we've done it again today chris great
work as always enjoy your weekend at
home you need a you need a break after
all the time you've been at home
i i know it's been hard for you you did
a great job cutting your own hair i
still think you cut your own hair i
wouldn't i did not cut my own hair but
yup i'm excited for the weekend
nonetheless three day weekend lots of
daddy cigars coming my way ready to go
here we go baby what are you what are
you going to do though turn your head
what are you going to do it's getting a
little bushy there on the side what are
you going to do
it's bothering me like legitimately like
to the point where i've actually thought
about man maybe i should ask my wife
just to get the buzzer out and just go
for it and see what the hell happened
but i don't think i'm gonna do that i'm
not that crazy i'm gonna have to do i'm
gonna have to do something here within
the next couple of weeks
it's getting a little shaggy i'm gonna
let it go though i'm not i mean what can
you do
right you got to i can't go to the
barber and the barber ain't coming here
and i don't trust my wife with with uh
scissors in her hands because i'll have
a flashback to all the smart ass things
i've said over the past six months and
wondering whether or not the scissors
are gonna end up somewhere somewhere
other than on my hair
yeah i think they would
on that happy note uh everybody have a
great day chris enjoy your your uh your
few days off although we know you'll
still be working you'll be studying film
other position groups as the draft
approaches and we'll have chris back on
monday we'll see everybody else on
friday for another edition of pft live
enjoy your day
see ya
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports